talk about the Facebook nonsense and
Andrew Tate is banned from social media
with videos about many women but when
exactly does Free Speech become hate
speech and who should get to decide that
joining me now are political journalist
Ava 17 and talk to the contributor
Esther Krakow uh author and podcaster
and friend of Andrew Tate Leia Hale Pern
and Times columnist Hugo Rifkin Hugo let
me start with you thank you for joining
the show original uh big times interview
um with this guy Andrew Tate I found it
very interesting because I knew I was
going to interview him on television uh
shortly afterwards and what I was struck
by was that although you were pretty
outraged by some of the stuff he said
and done and found it personally pretty
offensive you you didn't really seem to
be able to conclude that he'd really
crossed a line that deserved the
punishment he's received in terms of
social media Wipeout would that be a
fair categorization
yes I wasn't convinced because I'm not
look because I'm not quite sure what
debate we're having here it seems given
to me that there would be no place for
Andrew Tate on a on a normal
conventional
um media Outlet they're not going to
give him your show they're not going to
give him my show on times radio that
wouldn't happen but it raises the
question of whether we think that these
tech companies Instagram Facebook
companies like that ought to be being
held to the same standards as
traditional media if we think they
should be then obviously he has no place
in them if we think they're actually
more of a a much more free Arena where
things that we might find in other
places unacceptable are in fact
acceptable there then it becomes a whole
different debate and that's the debate
we haven't quite settled I think right
because I mean to me it's up when Trump
got removed from Twitter and Facebook
and so on if you're going to let the
Ayatollah of Iran continue to have
active accounts on these platforms I
don't see the consistency in Banning a
president of the United States or indeed
someone like Andrew Tate
yeah I mean that's that's uh that's
quite fair you've also got to accept
that look huge numbers of people wanted
to watch him huge numbers of people
wanted to listen to him he's he's very
very good at what he what he does in an
earlier age there were people at Andrew
Tate who put out cassettes and CDs over
on you know various forms of of Pirate
Radio they had huge audiences the
audiences are much much Huger now and
they are and much less policed he has
they have much greater inroads people
like Tay into into teenagers for example
so it raises whole new questions whole
new issues I'm not always convinced that
just Banning them is quite the right
answer but then I'm not sure I quite
like to be making that call myself right
I think that's a really good point uh
Leia Halburn uh you're in Miami you know
Andrew Tay you've been to his home in
Romania uh you know his brother
um what kind of guy is he I mean many
people who don't know much about him
will hear some of the stuff he's been
saying which I play to him and challenge
him on in the interview and they'll be
horrified but what do you think
he's an incredibly intelligent man
um I think what he's doing is very
important right now there's a huge war
on masculinity men don't really have any
kind of role model that they can look up
to
um Andrew has been very kind and very
generous with me um like I said I know
him personally I also known from a
business standpoint um I've spent time
with him one-on-one I've never felt
uncomfortable he's never been
inappropriate with me um a lot of people
accuse him of misogyny he's never been
misogynistic towards me and I think what
he's doing is incredibly important
okay Ava Santina your view of this I
mean just from The Exchange we just put
a preview of where he says he prefers 18
19 year old woman to 25 year olds I
think I think you're 25 aren't you
um but you know when he generalizes
about 25 year old women in the really I
thought pretty repulsive manner that he
did in public uh I think that is
misogyny actually because he's branding
a whole category of women in a very
offensive way I think it's close to
misogyny I think it's actually more
looking at women as a objectively sexual
objects which inherently is misogynistic
but it's looking for Purity in women
what he's essentially saying between
those lines is that he wants some sort
of virginal woman maybe that's why he
takes this girl seriously I don't know
but I mean it kind of sounds a little
bit like on the other side he's allowed
to I mean he can have these views does
anything that he say says all the stuff
that you've seen with him does it cross
a line where he deserves to be expunged
from all social media to be banished
from the internet when you you've got to
look at the reaction that came off that
so the people who were due his videos
are the people who were spreading his
messages when you've got 15 year old
boys espousing these sort of views while
you're talking about women in purely
sexual terms and that has come from
Andrew Tate and that's where the problem
is what do you think I don't I don't
actually think that's a very fair
assessment he didn't say oh I I just I
only date 19 years I prefer he was
making the point and he could have
phrased it better absolutely but he's
saying he did concede actually yeah but
the point he's making is and he's a very
intelligent guy like Leo was saying so
he knows what he's doing when he's
saying that obviously he's got a massive
reaction from it so clearly it's worked
but the point is you know he's saying
that younger women who have had less
experience with men in general are more
desirable because they don't come with a
certain amount of baggage now you could
say they're women that are more
experienced that come with less baggage
because they know what they want or
they're more mature but my view is he
shouldn't be talking about women in that
generalized way at all of any age I know
a lot of 25 year old women in my time
they're all very different it's like the
idea that you bracket them all in this
revolting way which he did which is just
a lad in the nightclub kind of way it's
fine but that's I do it with a big
following I think is a malevolent and
what is implied there is their sexual
history that is what he's talking about
yeah but they're women that are 18 that
have a more elaborate sexual history
well let me ask let me ask Hugo you know
you spent quite a lot of time with him
for your big interview for the times
what did you actually make of him by the
end when you came away what did you
think of him
oh we've gone very well but then we were
two men sitting in his cigar room
bantering you know we had a good we had
a good chat and a very honest chat I
mean we had a very similar conversation
to the conversation you're having at the
moment I think in different
circumstances I wouldn't have liked to
introduce him to my wife I wouldn't like
to have to hang out with him with my
female friends I think that'd be
intensely uncomfortable but I noticed
the way that at the moment what we're
doing we're debating whether whether or
not he's nice whether or not the things
he thinks are nice or right what we're
not debating is whether or not they
should be allowed right and I think it
slightly worries me that we've drifted
into thinking those are the same debates
I agree when did we already become the
moral Arbiters for whether people should
be allowed a social media platform I
mean let me go back to Leia I mean to me
you might find Andrew Tate's views
offensive unsavory misogynist as I did
on some occasions with him although he
and he made some concessions in the
interview I'm not sure by the end that I
concluded he'd done anything really so
heinous he deserved the punishment he's
got that was my real conclusion
yeah I don't think he said anything
wrong I think all he's doing is talking
about reality and I don't think it's
misogynistic to say you prefer a woman
that's 18 versus 25. it's literally just
a sexual preference it's the same reason
I don't think that's the misogyny I had
this argument with my sons though when
they saw the clip the misogyny isn't
that he has a preference for girls of 18
19 25. the misogyny is in the way he
talks about every woman who's 24. if
they're all the same and they've all
been through this Audrey background
which he finds so distasteful that's
obviously ludicrous well
I think I think he speaks with a lot of
hyperbole his goal was to go viral
obviously as Esther mentioned not all 25
year old women have been sleeping with
every single man that they meet in the
nightclub so there's always exceptions
but I just think in general a 25 year
old woman obviously has had more
experience than an 18 year old woman and
some men prefer that some men don't like
that and I think that's completely fine
I think what's what really scares me is
the censorship that we see online on
Twitter there's actually porn on Twitter
you have terrorists on Twitter and yet a
man who's just talking about reality and
the real dynamics between them you know
what I gotta say I have to say Leia I
think you make a good point I think
there are the Taliban have Twitter
accounts the artillery of Iran he's
threatened to wipe out Israel has a
Twitter account you know Donald Trump
doesn't Andrew Tate doesn't why you know
I can't really get a satisfactory
response from these platforms it's a
very interesting debate I think to be
had we're going to run the full
interview with Andrew Tate uh well the
whole thing will appear on YouTube by
the end of the week we're going to run a
good hour of it uh nature of the week it
is a fascinating watch I have to say and
you might like him you might hate him
but the real question is should he be
banned thank you to my panel thank you
to Hugo thank you to Leia uh that's it
from me